hello china's defense minister has
issued a stark warning foreign
interference in taiwan is quote doomed
to fail waifunker's address that the
shangri-la dialogue in singapore focused
on beijing stands on taiwan
tensions between china and the u.s are
front and center on the last day of the
summit on saturday the u.s defense
secretary lloyd austin accused beijing
of intimidation and aggression towards
taiwan
china says the island's reunification
with the mainland is inevitable
we will resolutely crush any attempt to
pursue taiwanese independence let me
make this clear if anyone dares to see
taiwan from china we will not hesitate
to fight we will fight at all costs and
we will fight to the end this is the
only choice for china
well we have two correspondents covering
this story adrian brown is in hong kong
but first let's bring in jessica
washington she's joining us live from
that summit taking place in singapore
right now so what more did the chinese
foreign minister have to say jessica
well in just a short speech he covered a
range of topics mostly discussing the
regional flash points but throughout the
speech he made a point of really
contrasting the way china describes the
u.s approach in the asia pacific versus
what beijing's approach is he
characterized beijing's approach as one
that is inclusive one that is supportive
to helping the region develop one that
has
serious ties with the region and is
respectful of the region versus the way
he characterized washington as a
meddling unhelpful partner in the region
apart from of course those strong
quotes on taiwan the minister also
talked about other contentious issues
such as the south china sea he he raised
that he himself and his counterparts in
asean have successfully been able to
manage these issues and that
freedom of navigation is in fact not
under threat as the u.s minister
said yesterday in his address he also
added when talking about the south china
sea that it is important that countries
that are actually in the region should
prevent countries that are outside the
region from turning these waters into
troubled seas so throughout the speech
really a message that the asian region
is for asia to manage and that the us
should really not meddle in its affairs
china also throughout the chinese
minister also throughout the speech
accused washington of attempting to
bully china that was something that he
alluded to many times throughout the
speech he also stressed that beijing
would never bully other countries in the
region and he really stressed that that
is the point of difference between
washington and beijing's approach all
right thank you so much jessica
washington reporting for us from
singapore let's get the view from hong
kong and bring in adrian brown so does
china have reason to feel threatened
adrian
well we've heard talk before about war
over taiwan not just from china but also
of course from the united states it's
been going on for decades we've heard
this hostile language
time and time again the difference now
of course is that militarily china is
much stronger than it was five years ago
and of course ten years ago it now has
an aircraft carrier and several more in
the pipeline the message the overriding
message coming from the defense minister
from china today was this
the time for trying to contain china is
over
asian
asian countries though of course are
feeling nervous they don't want to find
themselves in a position where they are
forced to take sides they want to deal
with china because china is the region's
biggest economy they want to deal with
the united states because the us is the
world's biggest economy
china is also concerned about something
else it's what it says is a nato style
security block that the united states
wants to establish in this region now
that block would comprise japan
australia india and the united states
and china has accused the united states
of trying to re-hijack countries in this
region
beyond taiwan and it remains the
principal flashpoint here at the moment
there is deepening concern on the u.s
side about what it says are dangerous
and provocative
aerial and also naval maneuvers being
taken by its military not just in the
area of taiwan but also in the south
china sea and the east china sea and the
big worry is this is that the military
brinkmanship could one day spiral out of
control all right thank you so much
adrian brown reporting from hong kong